coal-fired power stations polluting
relics of the UK's industrial past
these days they generate a tiny
percentage of the country's electricity
but the National Grid which is charged
with keeping the lights on likes to have
some on standby to help prevent
blackouts when it's very cold and wind
power generation is low we've been
looking at the risk associated with
Russia's continued invasion of Ukraine
one of the things that the secretary of
state has asked us to do is to talk to
the coal units that we used in a similar
manner last winter to see whether we
could secure their availability for this
winter but it seems that might not be so
simple here's the picture last winter
when the National Grid had five coal
units on emergency standby two here at
edfs West Burton Nottinghamshire one
here at Juniper's Ratcliffe On saw power
station nearby and two at Drax in
Yorkshire between them these coal units
were warmed a number of times just in
case and actually used once during the
Cold Snap in March
but this winter things are looking much
less certain wesburton a has closed as
planned it's far too old to stay open
Ratcliffe is going to be used for
routine commercial power generation and
therefore isn't available for
emergencies and now it appears that Drax
the only real remaining option is very
unlikely to be able to help
in a statement a spokesperson told Sky
News as we announced in April we have
closed our coal units at Drax and have
started the decommissioning process
since then we have had various
discussions with government and the
National Grid electricity system
operator but we are not in negotiations
to extend their availability into the
coming winter the grid says it has
plenty of other tools at its disposal to
help balance the system it is likely to
keep using its demand flexibility scheme
which pays consumers to use less at
times of peak demand but some believe
the rush to phase out coal completely by
October next year is a mistake we've had
situations where there's been low wind
output in the summer it's not just the
case that we need these contingencies in
the winter we need all year round to
have the tools to manage different
weather patterns as the weather becomes
more important to the amount of
generation that we can produce
an example of the complexities and
challenges involved as the UK continues
its transition to clean power Hannah
Thomas Peter Sky News